d'abord on regarde vers la gauche et sur
le silo de graff à 1 tour 11 jours et un
vendômois qui après immersion chez les
habitants du quartier ont retransmis bon
en main leurs préoccupations et leurs
aspirations
quand on a eu 35 questionnaire où le
thème qui revient c'est la paix à
arrêter la guerre que des choses comme
ça avec différentes phrases mais l'idée
principale elle était là donc on vous
pouvez pas ce quiz et cette chose là et
là dessus qu'on est parti au niveau de
notre création
on sait ce qu'on a envie de faire on a
même presque pas besoin de se parler et
puis les idées fusent on échange et puis
à sas mais sur papier et sur papier ça
devient un mur de l'autre côté des voies
ferrées le manège du quartier rochambeau
est en effervescence
vingt-cinq artistes de la région achève
dans l'installation ou le cadre de leur
performance ce ne sont pas les allées
traditionnelle d'un salon mais bien une
ville
on veut une ville avec des rues des
places des impasses un labyrinthe où les
gens vont rentrer dans des espaces des
fausses maison des kiosques un cinéma
factice un plateau de tournage une
maison témoin mais qui n'en est pas une
on veut de la surprise on veut que les
gens se perd pour mieux se retrouver
cette triennale de vendôme est un
premier rendez vous et c'est aux
visiteurs jusqu'au 31 octobre d'en faire
un rendez vous incontournable